I always say if people be looking at me
crazy like I don't know if this cuz I'm
from Chicago but like okay that working
up in the fire I don't know why I just
need a fast money or like for fraud but
like like rapping or like dealing with
media or like like that just like come
on Friday day I need you to get that
right now like so I feel like it
appeared with the 9 to 5 like if you not
in the Father Burger King or some no but
if you not the father
my favorite JP Morgan I some hell yeah
Friday check but the help she that's the
fraud we're gonna Bank no I don't want
you Wow okay see like JP Morgan or Evie
fry you know tingling he he be working
the banking Nami like you know Friday
you went in the bank what she mean
frying is that slang for something what
frying is it slang for something it's
like Friday front o rotting so he said
writing
I heard frying North Friday fraud okay
[Music]
let's say to [ __ ] that working to be
going on I never watch this video on
honest I'm kind of glad I didn't want to
cover initially because now I'm watching
like why am i covering this yeah this is
just a lost person yeah this a woman is
just lost it I don't think it's
reflective of a trend with ladies I
don't think it's any of that because
generally ladies like stability in a man
I don't think there's nothing stable
about a man who could be sent to prison
at any point so this is not indicative
of some trend I'm not saying that
there's not a pocket of society where
this exists
but this is dumb talk this is goofball
talk what does a nine-to-five not have
to do with the hustling mentality it's
not because you worked as 9:00 to 5:00
that you're not hustling where is the
correlation people had this idea of
hustling like you always have to be some
entrepreneur and you have to have 20
streams of revenue no working at your
job diligently and working towards
better promotions and better raises is
also a great thing she could say all she
wants about 9:00 to 5:00 is this nine
defines that you know you put some
athlete it looks great at first then he
gets injured and he doesn't know how to
use his money properly yeah it's fast
money it's great that fast money can dry
out fast it's not because you make fast
money that you know how to keep money
for a long time you might be able to get
in the short but who says you can keep
it in a long the benefit of working 9:00
to 5:00 East ability long term so that
when you're in retirement
you've got taxes that you've paid out
you've got four oh ones you've got
retirement funds that you can pull from
but no you're not thinking about that
because you just want to live in this
moment well good luck in the future
good luck when you fall hard times yeah
good luck in the future but a lawyer
banker look he's not gonna vote for you
what do you have to bring to the table
you have all these demands and that's
fine that's all good that's all cable
boo honey chicken but what are you gonna
bring I don't know to me like you saying
yeah I would go for those guys but they
wouldn't go for you wanna go for you if
you're not on the same page as me I
can't put you like I need to be like I
need 50,000 by next Friday what you
feeling gonna do to get this oh why
gotta wait to the the checks you're like
no [ __ ] [ __ ] you know
but Nick made 500,000 year I'm pretty
sure he got 50,000 listen this girl is
lost she's lost it's not a thing I
wouldn't go like all girls are not girls
around me or don't have that kind of
talk and it's just one girl that has
that kind of talk it's not it's not most
people you don't want a knife what do
you bring this is someone I wouldn't
even waste my breath on so I have to
reply to them like this sort of Connor's
like what do you need 50k next week for
that's what I would wonder I don't care
listen I make a decent titoki chicks
right if my girl came to me in a week I
need 15k next week for what is the back
knee needs to be redone that's not 50k
oh well you can't give me that I'm out
what there's the door
what why are you coming to me view you
need 15k where's your 15 care if you had
some savings right and maybe if you had
a 9 to 5 mentality where you focus on
stability then maybe when you need a 15k
whenever you wanted you won't have it
that's the funny thing about this
pandemic man it's doesn't change
everybody people out here snitching
people are fighting each other people
are you're breaking quarantines yelling
at cops yelling at politicians all this
stuff people are voting differently
right politicians want to do all these
handouts and all this it's different but
then some of these is still mad basic
that's the thing that kills me some of
y'all time has not changed times are
changing but not baby you know they
still so basic like baby - man that's
easy I hear some basics be talking about
some dumb dumbs like wait what's all
this what is this don't you have things
to do right there Damon you guys as
viewers know what to do if you encounter
a basic block like this don't engage
walk away you don't even need to explain
yourself you don't even need to try
explain why she's wrong yeah but you
would understand cuz you're not one of
the men making that kind of money okay
okay sure whatever you say but if I was
I still wouldn't mess with you so then
what then what that was the dumbest
thing cuz you get your paycheck in two
weeks I can't [ __ ] with you bye well bye
and any kind of guy who engages with a
girl like this is probably a symphony
wise man [ __ ] and
I mean 15 K right now of course baby for
what for what even if I have the whole
heap of money a year even if like in the
bank there's a bunch of million dollars
sitting there looking at me waiting for
me to spend it on a boat a year yeah be
like yo I need 15k for what yeah what do
you need 50k for yeah the fridge is full
yeah the gas tank is full I've got a car
you got a car right watch your knee 50k
for what did you do
what kind of rinky-dink drug deal did
you go through that you need 15 game for
and you can enjoy that fast money now
but when the cops come knocking they
take everything back so all that stuff
that you bought the cars the properties
all that stuff that you bought with
whatever kind of fast money that person
got they will be repossessing even the
thing that you did about with the money
because they don't know if they got it
for that sometimes I happens so they
take everything everything watch you get
recode it's not a pretty sight so listen
if you think like her I hope you change
before it's too late because I can
assure you most people who I've seen
tape dudes in this realm end up way
worse off then if they had been what
they do with a stable job and at the end
of the day that's look cute now but when
you're getting your 40s 50s you know out
of you something who's wilder now look
at all those rappers they might start
off with that talk but one thing in
their 40s and 50s what do they do they
switch it up quick things isn't that
correct like that no they in the
relationship yeah yeah that's high
school look at some millionaire right
they see me rollin now they see me
investing all right tech companies all
day look at the way they move Rick Ross
is the same way huh no right went from
parole officer to rapper to what now
he's a mogul that's the way it functions
it's not tenable you need some form of
stability even for us this YouTube thing
if the platform becomes too unstable
we're gonna move somewhere else gotta
gotta stay moving you gotta change they
remember the girls back in the house we
were like yo girls I want bad boys like
that that's what it is that's what it is
in the same girls I was in high school I
was talking about yeah you're not man
enough you're not this you're not that
you're too boring by boring boring is
not
talking about I don't eat it's like yeah
you don't engage in those kind of stuff
and I look at you yeah 34 five children
guys inside and then you wait waiting
for the next one come on now now see
somebody brought like this to where they
messed with a bunch of bad boys early on
and then the end up with some goofy nerd
at the end why because they learned the
error of their mistakes as well
the goofy nerd what does he do he's
making Bank and he's not his you know he
is gonna bring that money that paper and
he's responsible with stuff like that no
that's just dumb talk this is don't talk
from a dumb person this is not a
interesting it's not a thing it's not a
thing it's not a thing so don't make it
a thing all right don't look at this and
be like man we made our trip this is not
women this is a goofy broad and some
goofy other broads but ain't nothing big
to me it's like the equivalent of the
people who like glorify like gang life
this is exactly what it is gene but
that's exactly here I'm a [ __ ] tired
debt okay but that's exactly okay see
well that ends up for you about it
that's exactly what it is
[Music]